the city of los angeles is set to
receive a windfall of more than 1.3
billion dollars in bailout money
and liberal mayor eric garcetti is
ecstatic
to spend it on his left wing agenda
now with this money we can put that
money back into the savings account
we can pay off the credit card deliver
life-saving mental health services
and unarmed response as we reimagine
public safety money to improve our
pensions
we'll lower people's health care costs
support students with disabilities
here to react are two los angeles
restaurant owners whose businesses were
trampled by garcetti's strict lockdowns
chef and owner of slap fish restaurant
andrew grull
and owner of pineapple hills saloon and
grill angela marsden thank you both for
being here ladies first angela i'll
start with you
that video you made touched everyone
because it was such a blatant example
of hypocrisy between the movie set and
your restaurant eric garcetti said he's
flushed with cash now
what should he do with it you know what
i i it's interesting the clip that you
just played not once did he
say anything about giving the money back
to the people
like helping the small businesses
helping the
unemployed from the small businesses you
know los angeles
is the number one city in the united
states of the most small businesses lost
and we're dealing with a mayor who
basically keeps the money for himself
and doesn't spend it on the people la
needs that money
for sure because of his his total
mismanagement
and you know pay to play things that are
going on we already have two people
within our city
that have been um charged with pay to
play
that work under him um the money never
goes where it's supposed to go
so i i wish the money was given to him
with strings that allocated it
towards the people that really need it
like our small businesses
our homeless we spent 430 million
dollars on the homeless last year
and it went up what almost 16 percent i
mean the money
unfortunately um is not going to go
towards helping stabilize the backyard
of los angeles
and the family members the community
members of los angeles as you can see
he didn't mention any of that on where
the money was going to spend put it in
the bank
we have the largest homeless crisis
going on right now and he's talking
about putting money in savings
i mean i i i don't know what planet this
guy lives on no it's true
i was in los angeles recently the
homeless problem there is like
something i've never seen before uh chef
are you confident that any of this money
will go
to i don't know the people that he
locked down for a year
no of course not i mean look he's
rewarding himself for failed policies he
did an
awful job and now he's going to be paid
one you know you know billions of
dollars for this
there's 10 000 restaurants in the
greater los angeles area you could give
every single restaurant 50 000
and still have roughly a billion dollars
left over that he could dole out
to break the cycle of homelessness
perhaps to help other small businesses
throughout los
angeles you see what he's doing is he's
using the money to fix problems that
probably existed
prior to coronavirus could you imagine
if i tried to get ppp money
for businesses that i shut down that
were underperforming two years leading
into coronavirus and were already shut
down
that's exactly what's happening here
covent relief money to fix things that
happened before
covid based on failed liberal policies
that are still there
not helping the people who've actually
been locked down andrew gruel angela
martin you've both been very courageous
outspoken we're grateful you're on the
program
keep us posted out there thank you very
much